did you see the liver King no what
happened his uh blood tests got leaked I
don't know I think maybe someone who
worked for like the testing company or
something leaked his emails and they're
all like his signature and it's like
thanks liver King and apparently it's
[ __ ] crazy how much how much [ __ ]
he's taking this guy was taking a
hundred and thirty two thousand dollars
of HGH a year a year dude the ridiculous
thing is he was taking three different
HGH boosters and they still weren't
raising the levels of igf HGH makes your
liver excrete it goes on so many
steroids and funny this guy wasn't on
like a little HH trt this guy was taking
us there was to kill you at 45. he wrote
this in an email yeah to someone and
then they leaked it yeah I've been
working out for 35 years I know how to
eat train and recover but as I've
reached my mid-40s it's getting harder
and the back fat [ __ ] sucks or
something yeah so he's a fraud oh no I
would have thought dude the whole time
who would have thought liver King yeah
man he's not real